I was snooping and I found some messages
I didn't love online to this dude a lot
of talk about where people live and [ __ ]
and so as soon as I see we're exchanging
where we live I'm nervous because you
know who else lives in that house me
everybody
yeah yeah right so I need to know who
what the [ __ ]
so we confront her and I'm like who
what's going on and she's like I love
him and he's a bad how old is she she's
probably 14 and I wanna you know I love
this guy and and he's my soul mate and
right then I'm like mmm
no he's not basically we got into this
[ __ ] about like how when she's like how
do you know he's not I'm like Pete
because it's online and this is early
online I'm like you don't know nobody is
there themselves online she goes he's
himself I go are you when he responds to
you do you just write free flow or do
you think about what you want to say do
you think about what you want to say and
she's like yeah I go and this website
you're on is for cosplay and anime
what's your avatar a picture of you or
is it like a sexy anime character so are
we being ourselves how do I know this
dude isn't some guy at the high school
with you know what I mean like what the
[ __ ] but she was adamant and I said okay
and he was in um he lived in Missouri
and I was getting ready to go do a show
in Missouri a with Larry the Cable Guy
and um so I was like you know what Beth
my wife I said I'm gonna take I'm gonna
take her we're gonna meet this guy and
I'm gonna prove to her that he's not
real
oh my so that's out there right because
not because you know what dad's like as
much as their kids having fun and
enjoying themselves being right I was
just about to say being right oh man how
badly do you know how badly I was
looking forward to being right you know
how I knew I was gonna be right I go let
me see a picture of this guy because all
I saw was the avatar I go do you even
know what he looks like and she was yeah
I send me a picture so she printed it
out do you know the picture he sent he
sent her this is Lawrence Taylor dude
[Laughter]
[Applause]
sent her a photoshopped picture you know
like a like kind of Art Deco doubt of 21
Jump Street Johnny Depp so and she
doesn't [ __ ] know 21 Jump Street and
so he probably is your age so she said
to me and he's so cute I'm like oh he he
is cute I'm like he this guy right here
he's one of the best-looking people
who's ever walked Planet Earth
and I'm like I told Beth I'm like I feel
very confident let's take her on the way
there she tells me um and she's by the
way the plane trip she buys him these
chocolates I'm so excited to give these
salads and about an hour and she's gonna
have one
she's japako and she was like he
wouldn't mind if I bang - right because
- and there's two of us and she had
another one she was like you know I'm
just gonna split it with him I'm gonna
have and by the time we man is just like
but on the plane when she's eating her
chocolates I'm super excited and so
chatty she tells me one of the reasons
that she's also excited to go she's
never been kissed before and she wants
him to be her first kiss and now there's
a lot of conflict for me dude because I
still want to be right but this is such
a it's a unique experience for me to be
able to be part of the fact that she
asked me she's I'm with her and she's
telling me this is such a crazy thing
for a daughter to say to her father
so I want to be right you know what I
mean but I know we're not gonna run into
Johnny Depp so I'm instantly thinking if
she gets past the initial disappointment
for whatever [ __ ] no one's defeated
elevator we might run in there
oh hang him lazy and Johnny been not in
Poplar Bluff Missouri yeah all right so
she's holding up a picture of Johnny
Depp looking for him and I feel like
telling her he's not he's not gonna be
here let's let's lower the paper and
look for the what seems like it's gonna
fit because I know you've I've never
heard this I'm coming with her I know
he's coming with his dad the stories in
my book so if you and it's a little more
extended in there but so I I'm looking
for who I think fits dad son looking
around also we're out in front of the
arena where I'm playing with Larry the
Cable Guy so we told him to come to the
show because the dad is a huge layer the
Cable Guy fan so shocker so yeah so I
see - father-son walking up and this kid
is not Johnny Depp
he is the pan you know when you see
someone who's so pale
like the like heat like he stepped in a
pail a pail like have you been in under
the ocean like that kind of like the
color of my legs you've seen mother yeah
so he's walking up with this dude I'm
like hey Kate and he was Ronnie yeah
yeah it's close so it walked up and he
see he knows what Kate looks like and he
goes
cuz he knows the picture he said man she
sent a real one yeah cuz she she cuz she
doesn't look like an underwater creature
you know so she goes Kate and I could
see her go her face just was like but
I'm their first kiss she doesn't want to
admit to me that she's right she's just
like hey and they real awkward and I
shake this dude's hand real nice dude
I'm gonna give you one distinguishing
feature on it the dad or the kid the
dead okay
this is not a judgment on the man I'm
just telling you what I'm looking at
it doesn't matter he was dressed like
all I need to tell you is you know your
front eight teeth I'm familiar with a
lot to you yeah so you probably never
thought of your front eight because
you've got them all my man had one
klonda and it was an extra-long front
tooth that hung over his little bottle
of dude it looked like that tooth ate
all the other teeth you know what I mean
like there can only be one it's right
[Laughter]
and it was long dude like every all the
calcium apparently when he ate it went
to that one too and the other teeth are
like it's just where they withered away
not even so I'm looking at this dude I
see you know the guy that shows up
that's not that's Ronnie Ronnie Depp so
I got ronnied up in this dude
and Ronnie says to me my dad is really
excited to be here this is their the
Cable Guy as his hero and there are
almost ten times the amount of people in
that arena in our that I are in a
hometown so this is like a huge deal for
us so thank you so much I am out of
teeth yeah so I we go in there right up
front the one good thing I will tell you
man and I genuinely like the one thing
that about this on a side note just to
see how happy this dude was was so cool
it also gave me such a great perspective
on like home just here to do the show
this was this was the biggest day of his
life
he's getting treated like royalty yeah
way better than identity
so so like it was really things like
that always helped me with perspective
like well I have a pretty cool gift yeah
we do do you know what I mean yeah
remember yeah
what do you remember what it was like so
we had the show and they're sitting
front we go backstage this was a little
embarrassing when in backstage later the
Cable Guy is Dan Whitney he's got a
different accent
does he audit no yeah I had that I
thought that was his act no no different
accent so he the guy walks back and I
got him in the greenroom he's super
excited to meet Larry the Cable Guy and
he says hey how I just got one question
big fan I've never thought I'd be able
to meet you and dance the most gracious
dude and he's like I'm great thanks for
coming to show the guys I just got one
question
how come you use your real accent on
stage and your fake one back here and
cable guy never took his eyes off of
them it just goes I'm sorry who brought
you yeah we're like my fourth gig with
this dude I'm like hey man but we walk
out and so I'm like hey everybody I'd
like to treat for dinner let the kids
talk a little bit whatever you want to
eat this is third he goes I go whatever
you already eat and he goes whatever or
whatever he goes I'd like to eat a steak
and I was thinking I'd like to watch you
eat it this is I think this is a good
idea right so we get in the car and but
when he said steak he was like I saw
there's a Steak and Shake I'm like yeah
whatever let's go take a shake you want
you on good stay yeah okay top knots all
right so when we get in the car I got to
get all my jokes out now do you know
what I mean I gotta get my daughters
there I'm like so how do you think he
eats a steak do you think his son choose
it for him and then puts it on his plate
or does he say when you how do you want
your steak cooked blended like whatever
how do you think he doesn't
does he floss with a thimble does he
just put it over so she's like stop it
I'm like how's it going
she said well we're not exactly
soulmates and I said you you still under
this first kiss she does I kind of know
I don't know yet
okay well we still got time we get to
the restaurant
the longer they're sitting together the
more they realize they're not soul mates
and we pay for the food and the dude is
super nice the kid is super nice just my
daughter this is it's Ronny Depp that's
not Johnny yeah and he's running out of
things to say because he can't think
about his responses for an hour or a day
before he gets back to her so nice
enough kid but never we're walking out
and I say to her Kate do you want your
first kiss she's like well I go hey what
happens in Poplar Bluff stays in Poplar
Bluff I said but if you want to get the
nerves out of a first kiss until you
have your actual first kiss so you can
figure out a few things that you let's
just do it
she's let's get on it she was like you
think so I go do you want to she was
like I do I do I just want to get
actually cuz I came all this way I'm
thinking about so I catch them when
they're walking outside I go hey how
about we go back to the hotel and I was
like me you and I can sit in the lobby
and I told them I said there's a couple
chairs by the elevators you guys can go
sit there for like 15 minutes so they
walk over the chairs me and the dude sit
in hotel lobby this is the opening line
he goes you know my dad I ran over me
with a tractor when I was eight and I
was like yeah I hope this last 15
minutes I'm really interested in this
yeah do you know me well enough to know
that line hooks me
Oh hundred percent I'm done
[ __ ] that they can take an hour however
long it takes you to tell me this got
one tooth yeah and that's how you
wondering if the tractor cut that
[ __ ] mouth so my daughter they were
there for like three minutes my daughter
comes back she's like I'm ready gonna
I'm like yeah everything all right she
goes yeah I'm just ready and I go okay
you want say goodbye to her you go she
was like she kind of scares off the
elevators like
okay and I told the kid nice to meet you
son and you know and I tell the dude he
goes we should stay in touch I'm like
you know what hang out with your daddy
[Laughter]
let me know when you eat the cool when
you enter the point on the car
championship and I'll get there man
so I go watching me some quality fried
butter in there oh god dad look at him
the machine do you want to know how he
ate the steak yes of course
he cut it into little pieces but he
mushed it on the top of his roof of his
mouth with his tongue he went up on it
like him pushed it against that tooth I
guess the tongue must have gotten so
strong
you oughta maybe it's a muscle mother it
just kind of yeah and he would just you
team go I'm just kind of I was like that
is the [ __ ] so we go back we get in
the elevator where you go up to the room
we get in the hotel room me and her and
I'm in my bed and she's getting ready
hasn't said a word about it and I'm
pretending to watch TV and she sits and
on her bed and watch TV and I turn TV if
I go wait a second all of that we make
the plan first kiss you know
you tell me anything she goes all right
what I don't want to talk about it after
this I go okay she was we were sitting
there and I had I realized he had never
been kissed before either it was both
our first kiss and I went to lean in and
we leaned in too fast and he he had had
a giant pimple on his chin I thought you
don't say he had up one big bottom no no
[Applause]
he had one giant pimple and when they
they live too hard and her face popped
his pimple no and it squirted on her
face it exploded right so now all that
is sick gross you know me man I'm trying
not to laugh and I'm also trying not to
slap myself on the back for being right
but I'm also feel bad for my daughter
you know what I mean but it was the
craziest I learned by the way
tripping what I learned she pointed a
lot of things out to me about the way I
parented her she cuz she did a lot of
cosplay and anime and I leaned on humor
when I don't know things or
understanding what makes fun of it
yes and I sent them to her about and she
goes yeah but you don't care about that
I go what do you mean I listen to
everything you say and she goes yeah but
you call it you never pronounce it right
as a joke and you're always making some
sort of joke and but you never naked
joke about Jacob when he talks about
baseball or I go yeah but I understand
baseball she goes well then why don't
you just learn something about what I'm
doing put this sexy pan yeah
put these elven ears on but like but she
says she goes I know you think you're
there but you're not present you're not
there when I'm talking to you because
you don't care about what it is that I'm
doing I said I care she goes yeah but
not enough to find out what it is or
listen and you make a joke because you
don't know what I'm talking about and
that doesn't make it weird that just
means that you haven't taken the time to
figure out what I do and I was like yup
yep yep yep yep but she was a hundred
percent right but it was a great chip on
so many levels like I learned so much
about her I did learn a lot about myself
I was right it ended up being a great
story she come in for you to tell ya
well listen you know what I'm not so
concerned with that because at the end
of the day man even though I wanted it
to be and she obviously had a great real
first kiss and all this stuff
but the end of the day she deleted that
account and she's even said to this day
she was like yeah I don't believe
anything I read on there from anybody
which if it took one broken pebble Hey
job well done Danny you gotta eat listen
you got to break a couple pimples along
the way you know what I mean someone
else's face oh god that's it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you